Putin's invasion of Ukraine appears to be a
complete failure.
So why did Putin start the war in the first place?
Ukraine has one of the worst geographies in the world.
Its entire eastern border with Russia is just flat land,
which makes it super easy to invade.
In the north,
it borders Belarus,
which is controlled by Russia,
and there are no natural borders.
In fact, Ukraine's capital, Kiev,
is just 100 km away.
In the south,
Russia controls Crimea and the Black Sea
and can easily block Ukrainian ships.
Taking over Ukraine in three days
should have been an easy job for the Russian military,
but the Ukrainian people have shown that
as long as people are willing to defend their homeland,
you can win
even if you have really bad geography.